Hillary Clinton in spite of democrat
Witch Hunt against Twitter to look for
Russian accounts that simply didn't
exist and four social media giant into
the arms of the FBI then we got this one
Adam Schiff lobbied Twitter to ban
journalists over q a conspiracies and
then we got this one right from at Tibi
quote reporters know this is a model
that works
that's a cycle threaten legislation
wedded to scare headlines pushed by
Congressional Intel sources followed by
Twitter caving to moderation asks
basically the journalists ran on it so
what we have is the government colluding
with big Tech to shut down anyone who
had a descending opinion
welcome to the nightmare dystopia we
make fun of Canada all day and night ah
Canada's so bad tradoso Trudeau so bad
look what we're living in yeah yeah when
the when the care the trucker Convoy was
going Biden flew up there to tell
Trudeau to do something and then flew
back and they cracked down on it EMT
correct you Peter McCullough is losing
his medical licenses and credentials uh
he just lost it by the Texas Medical
Board and he's being threatened like
many doctors and and other doctors have
been stripped of their licenses for not
going along with the larger agenda it's
the thing that happens in Canada it can
happen here very very quickly that's why
we've got to speak up and get get loud
about this happening in California they
just passed a law that uh that doctors
can be held accountable for so-called
coveted misinformation if
you have a medical opinion that goes
against the government
there you go yeah that's crazy
but yeah to your point though I think
that like what is happening in Canada
like we can joke about it we can laugh
about it but it should also be a blaring
warning to all of us about what America
could become if we are not Vigilant uh
because this stuff we're seeing it at a
micro level in very blue States in
California you're seeing the code
misinformation laws targeting doctors
you're seeing you know people being
canceled for different opinions through
big Tech collusion you have you know
organizations like Prager you that
couldn't advertise on the internet
because we were apparently teaching
young people that they are not victims
and all these things it's it's absolute
insanity and it's like we literally will
become exactly what we fear in Canada if
we don't open our eyes and actually
fight to take back this country in a
real way what's the coveted
misinformation law in California you
mentioned yeah so it's literally if a
doctor says something that goes against
the you know the the current science of
of the matter so whatever you know fauci
is recommending or whatever they can be
held accountable and they can have their
medical licenses revoked and suspended
um whose authority under the medical
board of California that grants them the
licensing and this is if they just speak
out against an established if they
provide it if they provide medical
advice as contrary to that that they
believe is not helpful or I guess
fruitful to whatever they're trying to
accomplish then yeah they can be
reported to the medical board of
California where they can then face
penalties and sanctions for the medical
device if they don't Implement
um you know the procedures that the
government wants them to implement on
everyone else they lose their license in
in Germany there was just a doctor that
was sentenced to two years in jail
because he was giving out mask
exemptions and allegedly to the state he
was giving it giving out Mass exemptions
to the wrong people because of that he's
literally ending up in jail for two
years this it reminds me of what the
pharmaceutical industry did I think it
was in the 90s when they started
treating pain it was all about treating
pain and if you don't give them enough
opiates to treat their pain then you're
going to lose your medical license so
these doctors were forced to start
essentially drugging poisoning and
addicting people to opioids and Dr Drew
was talking about this on the episode
when he was on IRL is fascinating and
and it completely I mean he didn't
annihilate the medical industry but he
said doctors were in fear uh to practice
because they thought if they did what
they thought was the right thing they'd
lose their license this Pharma industry
is just too too tentacled in right now
and I'm not sure it's disgusting like
truly and truthfully if you can't trust
your physician to do what they believe
is right because they are fearful of
what the implications may be on their
ability to even practice medicine then
where can you truly get good advice
about anything anymore right can't get
it on Twitter you're getting banned from
there if you spread so-called well maybe
not now with Elon Musk at the helm but
before that was the case if you dare to
suggest an alternate theory about how
you should treat covid-19 or how you
should address it you were banned you
were censored in all these things it's
absolutely or even talking about early
treatment which we should have been
talking about which many Mainline
professionals are saying hey if there
was early treatment we could have saved
and prevented a lot of excess deaths we
could have prevented so much misery but
but the main consensus was like shut up
you're sick who cares uh come to the
hospital if you turn blue yeah that's
that's it
that's a proposal not not even that I
mean when when I got covered I called
the hospital and they said good luck
that's it yeah and then I was like okay
I guess and then I got really really bad
and so I did this don't I did what any
smart intelligent person would do I
called Joe Rogan
and that's half true when the hospital
was basically like stay home do nothing
I was like okay and then I ignored it
and then I started getting sicker and
sicker and then I knew Joe had talked
about the treatment he did so I hit him
up and then you know he was like get a
private doctor and talk to them about
options don't just like you can't rely
on these these like this public these
public hospitals are like we're
overwhelmed we don't care stay home
you're young don't worry about it and uh
yeah it's funny how that was like the
gag like Joe Rogan became this health
expert yeah that was funny well he he
platformed a bunch of Health experts I
don't think he would ever call himself a
health expert no I mean I mean I mean
that somewhat facetiously the media was
arguing he wasn't he wasn't saying he
was he made that comment about young
people not eating vaccines or whatever
then the media went nuts against him and
then he was like look the podcast
comedian like go talk to a doctor yeah I
trust him on nutrition that's for sure
he's definitely I don't know I wouldn't
consider him a nutritionist but do you
guys know medically regarding like
someone like Peter Mccalla who has Texas
strip his Texas state license can he
like go to Florida and get a license in
Florida not a practice but then he would
have to move or something probably so
like you could offer doctors sanctuary
in a state yeah okay I think yeah well
different states I would assume have
different like medical licensing
standards and so if you're stripped in
one state maybe there could be a
protection offered out and I'm sure if
he goes to Florida they'd reinstate they
gave him a license especially
considering Florida's position on most
things I'm more and more bullish that
DeSantis has got to stay in Florida's
governor yeah it's so I don't know I
mean I kind of feel like if he can bring
that leadership to the rest of the
country we'd be in a better position do
you think he can through the White House
yeah
I'm hoping to it he's not the
legislature here's the thing in Florida
you've got Republican legislature right
I'm pretty sure Luke
is Republican control legislature I
believe both Chambers so it's easy for
DeSantis to get things done when he's
got support in in you know Florida's uh
House of reps or whatever in Senate it
wasn't always like that though right and
that won't be the case in the right in
the United States if descendants becomes
president with a gridlocked congress
then he's not going to get things done
just he's sitting there saying no to
stuff but you still have a lot of power
and and you know at least we won't have
Dr fauci at the helm calling the shots
what if the Santa says the uh
is the guy who crosses the Rubicon you
think terrifying what would be the
Rubicon is it terrifying
the the yeah because that was a military
coup I understand but then you see 200
years was it like 200 years of
prosperity in the Roman Empire that's
debatable uh you got to find Prosperity
a lot of people the standard of living
plummeted after that well no I don't
know to be honest we talked about it
before and someone mentioned that it
actually improved a little bit I know
like Emperors are getting assassinated
back and forth yeah for a long time
leadership kept changing hands CJ what
do you think there's a big debate Trump
or DeSantis where do you stand you know
I think I think at the end of the day
DeSantis record is incredibly strong
right and I think to your point when you
talk about his the way that he's
maneuvered through the legislature
there's been times when they didn't want
to do a lot of the things that he's been
doing
um when you look at him redrawing those
uh Maps uh for congressional
representation there are a lot of people
in the legislature who are like no
DeSantis we don't want you to do that
and he was like no I'm gonna do it and
you guys are going to pass it and he did
it and I think that when you talk about
these really important culture wars are
in front of us about how do we actually
protect our children from grooming how
do we you know actually tackle things
like inflation and just get our country
back on the right moral course we need
someone who knows how to actually use
their power which I think
is one of the most prominent criticisms
of you know previous administrations is
that we have all chambers of government
but we don't know how to actually use
the power when we have it right why did
we not defund Planned Parenthood when we
controlled all chambers of government
that never happened and I think there's
no excuse for something like that
um it's it's because they don't actually
want to yeah I mean like you can't trust
them yeah we don't we didn't get term
limits we like if how long did it take
to repeal Obamacare if we ever really
ended up doing that in its entirety like
that's the thing it was it we had
someone on the show and they said that
um it was one of the freedom caucus guys
that he was the last vote to repeal
Obamacare and they came to him and said
no no don't do it we need it we needed a
campaign it's insane yep it's insane
that's what they uh McCarthy's team was
saying earlier today they were like
you know basically saying of Matt Gates
he he wins by losing yeah when the
Democrats win he can then campaign
against Democrats say they're the
problem he can blame the establishment
there's always a path and that's a
manipulation for sure like people like
Matt gates are elected because he is
fighting that's the game they play
exactly
uh I was plugging my computer in like I
was talking about controlled opposition
who is before you talk about Gates who
was the controlled opposition all of
them all politicians are controlling
their own but you were going on a little
time describing what was kind of going
on in Florida which I think was
interesting uh another thing that I
would add is that uh also one thing that
really kind of safeguarded DeSantis is
that he denied any Zucker bucks for
um reinforcing the elections uh down in
Florida because uh Facebook invested
hundreds of millions of dollars on
helping people vote predominantly
helping the Democrats vote and Florida
and DeSantis said no we're not going to
take your money and and I think because
of that that was one reason out of many
reasons why we had we you know the the
Santas had such a major victory down
there in Florida as well so it's
interesting seeing this larger fight
again there's a lot of also Shady people
surrounding themselves near DeSantis
because they kind of see him as this
kind of New Hope uh for me uh be
critical of everyone but I think the
record stands for itself I mean he's
he's very much against the woke he's
very much again the lockdowns the the
mandates the vaccines and he's actually
investigating it which is going to be
very fascinating to see the results of
these investigations when it comes to
myocarditis when it comes to people
getting ill getting sick and being
injured by this we're finally soon going
to find out what the correlation
actually is because his state is one of
the few states in the union that's going
to be tracking the data which I think is
extremely Brave extremely important and
something that we need desperately more
than ever yeah and you know let me make
myself clear too you know I love
president Trump and I love Governor Ron
DeSantis and whatever happens will
happen but I think what we truly do need
are people who number one are willing to
fight unlike what we have seen from
these establishment shells who have just
shown a reluctance to actually speak
truth to power at times and people who
are not afraid to take on the system and
use the Mandate that they have to
actually govern in a real way
um that's we like we can't go back to
the days of this passive conservatism
because that's not the battle we're in
today we have people literally trying to
change the genders of toddlers we have
you know this rampant indoctrination
happening in our campuses all across the
country we are in a battle for the heart
and soul of America we don't we're not
going to win that battle by being nice
anymore and I think that this this nice
guy era of politics it's unfortunate
it's come to an end but you cannot look
at the news each and every day and say
that it hasn't I think the key uh
economic is how to win politics is Win
economically because if you control the
market you control everything uh they're
all they all need money all these
politicians but let me I'll tell you a
story I I when I was uh 18 and I was
broke as broken B I had one pair of
pants and they were they the crotch
explodes right you skate in his pair of
stretch jeans eventually the crotch
explodes so what did I do I I got some
duct tape and then I just duct taped
both the outside and the inside and then
I pressed it with an iron and then uh
you know hey it's a patch start skating
in them ripped the lag I fell and I put
duct tape on both sides every time that
was a hole and then one one day I'm with
like some family and there's some buyer
for a big like you know department store
chain and then she's like those pants
are amazing did you make that and I was
like yeah and she was like wow that
Design's brilliant I was like it's not a
design I just have holes in my pants so
I duct tape them shut there is this
there is something about that
I don't know my my point is just
there it's not all about having the
money it's about the culture and the
culture can be developed by people who
don't have money and if you can
influence people you eventually will
make the money like if those pants did
end up selling you'd make a bunch of
money off garbage pants they sell those
hats where the brims are already Frayed
on it like it's yeah they sell they sell
pants that have fake underwear sewed in
it's it's it's it's a lot of it's fake
it's not about so much but but I don't I
don't disagree I'm in my statement it's
about the goods and the services and
some of those are Necessities I don't
think those should be for profit I think
but a lot of the the you know the
Cosmetic stuff people want that's
cultural like you you can create people
to want certain things and then so in
that sense it is the culture dictating
what Commodities people want in the
market and what then they're willing to
say it's the ESG essentially it's it's a
lot of the bigger Financial backers the
black rocks of the financial institution
saying No this is where the money is
going to be invested in this is where
the money is going to be put in this is
the ideas that we're going to promote
you promote any other ideas we're going
to take away our funding we're going to
put money where we want it to be funded
and that of course is destroying the
family unit degeneracy nonsense bullcrap
and the larger divide and conquer agenda
that are screwing over society and
destroying Humanity from the inside yeah
Vivek Rama Swami I'll bring it up again
uh on the show a few weeks ago I don't
know if you saw the episode or not but
he's uh he's an economist essentially
this I don't know if he considers
himself an economist if he's technically
one but he's uh talking about the
indexes and how BlackRock controls the
indexes they take your 401k if you just
give it to your company and then they
invest it in whatever they want and if
it's impact investment for climate
change whatever they're doing that so
he's created a new index a type of index
where people can send their 401ks local
or or send your investment in retirement
plans local to some company it's not
BlackRock yeah I believe Florida and
West Virginia also made very similar
moves uh themselves as well West
Virginia I think did it first with with
Banning that stuff Banning the answer
was West Virginia first day yeah thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time